[Music]
happy Monday everybody
this Monday man even think it was come
on
you've been living under a rock
[Music]
come on man
you've been you've been living under a
bad calendar man thank you guys for
being here with me this morning happy
Monday October 16th I'm in New Orleans
I'm actually I'm in Baton Rouge I'm in
Baton Rouge Louisiana and so if the
audio sounds a little bit weird or you
know loud or unload or you know tinny
sometimes they say that with audio it
sounds a little tinny you know the
little reverb I do not know I don't know
about all the different you know
specifics but I am in Baton Rouge
Louisiana man so I'm out here at my
brother's house and I'm in the dining
room and and this is where we're doing
the pod this weekend this week this this
uh this week so happy Monday hope you
guys had a good one I you was in New
Orleans for a wedding okay a fly-in
Friday into the Big Easy
go to this place Pascal's Manali right
and it's a it's a place where you can
get seafood and seafood you know what
that is man it's different food out of
the ocean or out of water it almost they
say seafood some of the stuff they serve
in Louisiana easily could have been
extradited from a ditch you know I mean
they got some things like [ __ ] if they
catch a dog that can swim they'll grill
that they will grill that thing up in
some places in Louisiana so the word see
I think is um you know that could be
used or not used things in water or
things from water I think is more
applicable I mean somebody will grill up
a [ __ ] spare tire if they find you
know and call SC food you know but we're
at this place Pascal's you know we
hadn't even gotten to the hotel or motel
or wherever we're staying my buddy and
his a flew in my buddy and his
girlfriend flew in on the same flight
I'm dropping them off at their Airbnb
and everybody's hungry we stopped at
this place we order some food right
we're sitting there chatting suddenly
somebody across the room starts choking
or choking to death I love you know
that's the thing about choking it's like
you know people it's either I guess it's
either you're choking or you're choking
to death there's not a lot of you know
middle ground when it comes to choking
and this person was choking I guess to
death you know we would we you know it
would take a while still to see so at
that time they were just choking I guess
somebody has to die to be actually
choking to death even though some of the
people were like I was choking to death
but they didn't die some of the people
say I was choking to death
and if you don't die you weren't you
were just choking but anyhow that
whatever this person is choking and they
stand up and everybody's just like
sitting down like pretending somebody's
not choking maybe to death and her
husband this guy this this no this
lady's choking you know when she had
kind of a I don't have you ever seen
Napoleon Dynamite but uncle Rico you
ever seen that dude his uncle who could
throw the football over the mountain she
had a haircut like his you know kind of
a like kind of a haircut that had been
blown blow-dried way too long
you ever see somebody there has been
blow-dried way too long and it seems
just lightly not crisped but just it
seems to almost fried a little a little
bit you know air fried not fried by
something wet but fried just by air it
seemed her her hair seemed kind of air
fried anyhow she's choking and her
husband I guess it's trying to help but
he's just like massaging her shoulders
and I'm like what the [ __ ] dude and so
I'm trying to make eye contact with him
before I try to get over there and help
because I don't know if this dude you
know I don't know what their
relationships like maybe he's you know
trying to kill his wife or something I
don't know but I don't want to [ __ ] up
their whole you know whatever they're
trying to do or he's you know if he's if
they're maybe she's horrible to him and
this is you know he
you know planned ahead on this sandwich
and this is you know the the meal that's
gonna take her out you know maybe he
can't afford a cruise you know a lot of
people take their spouse on a cruise and
they push them overboard while they've
been drinking maybe this guy's like you
know I'm gonna save money on a six
hundred ala cruise ticket and just hit
up this you know $14 you know oh boy
stop oh boy here in New Orleans anyhow
so she's choking this dudes like
massaging her shoulders so I'm I'm like
I'm gonna stay out of this because I
don't want to you know ruin whatever
money this dude is trying to make or you
know whatever and then the waiter comes
in everybody else is just kind of
chilling I stand up and I'm like does
anybody know you know what's going on
over here and it's a small room we're in
there's only probably 13 people in the
whole room and there's about maybe 12
tables and one of the tables is a five
top so I mean this lady's like spitting
and like I don't have you ever been
choking or not but it's pretty intense
have you ever been like choking -
choking possibly to death that [ __ ] is
intense you know and your face and your
your throat starts making all this extra
saliva you know you start turning your
whole head turns into like a water slide
I mean you start dripping out of your
eyes and your nose and everything cuz
you're you know your body's trying to
Lube your whole universe up so you can
get this whatever's inside of you so
it'll pop out and this lady's I mean
dripping she's like crying and his you
know grease coming out her pores and
like you know her ears are like saliva
is just swirling at her ears and
everything I mean she's this lady's
lubed up I mean you think she's ready
for some type of gangbang if she wasn't
choking possibly to death man I tell you
dude this this waiter comes over and he
straps on the Heimlich bro this start
this dude straps on the Heimlich and he
was the skinniest waiter you know I'm
not accusing anybody a different you
know you know extracurricular activities
but I've worked on the pizza line I used
to work and make make pizza with a guy
on methamphetamines and then boys can
put in work
you know and they don't weigh much I
mean this this dude had this guy I
worked with would wear a belt but he
would have to tie the belt you know in
his what his waist was basically just a
forearm with a spine in it you know in
some organs and some lean organs I mean
this boy was lean and so I've been
around these fellas that's jacked up on
them uppers you know that they call it
high diving you know when you own them
uppers constantly because you live in at
60 feet you know when it's I mean you
your world is just a bouncy board up
there anything can happen that fall can
be fast and and this is this guy this
lean fella starts doing Heimlich on this
lady and this lady's a you know she's a
middleweight light heavyweight maybe you
know she kind of she's not she's like a
Buster Douglas kind of if you will if
you want to use fight and terminology
she she she's sort of a Buster Douglas
and as he pulls on her his whole body is
coming up off of the ground
so this this guy is Heimlich and this
lean this lean fella dude he's Heimlich
in her it looked like a skeleton trying
to [ __ ] like a big animal as he's
pulling his his whole body is bucking on
her like his feet are coming up off the
ground his momentum and she's just I
mean this and suddenly there's just kind
of like a like a like that like and just
this big splash of like you know
whatever it was whatever it jacked her
system up just just just kind of just
attack it just flew I mean do a head
liquid flew out of her eyes nose and
mouth
you know the trifecta you know I mean it
was it was artful almost it was
something you'd see at Disneyland around
sunt around sunset when they do the big
water display and the water kind of
jumps from one hole to the other and
they're playing the music you know be
best be best you know and the music's
you know everybody was kung fu fighting
and them just the waters are jumping
and landing in other holes and it's like
this perfect thing it was like that man
it hit the air and it was just like and
just splashed and then everything was
done and it was over and it was awkward
man it was so awkward and I didn't know
what to do so I started a round of
applause because otherwise I'm thinking
here yeah well first of all the lady
lived you know if somebody lives hell
yeah
you know even if her husband had a plan
or he was caught up in the dark arts and
his brain you know he was thinking about
murder he'd been googling stuff that was
dangerous then would come back to haunt
him you know on a Dateline episode
whatever you know I mean I could see
some you know fella thinking about
taking his wife out via via sandwich
that's an easy that's a $17 kill you
know but this guy you know I got started
this run of applause as a run of
applause going and and that kind of
broke the awkwardness man and I've been
there let me tell you I have been there
okay I've had reactions if I have and
this is like and I'll know now given
this secret out to people but if I have
tuna fish and Gatorade same time just
straight tune out the can albacore you
know none of the cheap [ __ ] but if I go
albacore that white meat you know that
front meat that that breast of the fish
immediately if I have that with Gatorade
my throat shuts down I mean closes up I
remember being in a hotel in Chicago you
know I'm hitting myself with that
Gatorade that thirst quencher and I'm
popping off ah I got one of them bags of
cold bags of of tuna fish because some
time they used to have for a while and
they may still have them because it's
hard to get into a can of tuna I mean I
remember seeing a homeless guy beat open
a can of tuna with an umbrella once in
Santa Monica and I'm like [ __ ] that dude
you know that's that's aggressive for
some fish
you know for some low-key fish that's
aggressive so I'll I know that I'm not
that kind of guy you know I'm not that
kind of guy I'm not the guy that beats
open a can of tuna for you know with a
with a you know with a whether
prevention utensil but when when I mixed
this so that for a while they had it in
a bag and it was just a bag you could
seal tight you would open it and you
could get to the tuna right there
immediately there's a tuna it was kind
of this metal pouch pouch does a better
term than bag so I was in my hotel room
I'm running late I just hit the gym I
want to get you know electrolytes and
get my protein in so I hit up a 7-eleven
on the way to my room
grab me a bag of that snack fish that
low-key snack fish and a Gatorade and
the Gatorade man reitman and hit my
throat and I had the tuna in my mouth
and throat my [ __ ] closed up locked so
I'm in my hotel room and my [ __ ] is
locking locking bro you ever see like on
those movies where somebody attacks like
or somebody you know tries to think like
maybe Star Wars where somebody tries to
get on to the you know the space vessel
and the doors start closing whenever
they're you know finally are stealing it
or whatever in the the sliding doors are
to start locking down like blush foosh
it was like that I mean my throat
started locking I mean no entry
dude I am reaching down my own throat I
don't even ever reach down your throat
for something you know I'm trying to
think what I would compare it to first
of all never would I think I could get
my hand down my throat until I have to
dude I was just trying to hold my throat
open so I could get air in and out of it
man my throat keeps locking I try to
call the phone try to call the front
desk
I can't I'm like go into the hall right
into the hall I have my toothbrush in my
hands I'm trying to push that in my
throat and like hold it to the side to
hold my throat open go into the hall
man dude a man I'm pretty sure my eyes
were watery could have been a you know I
mean it's Chicago it could have been a
lesbian could have been a hearty lesbian
you know you know a third-degree lesbian
and and I am pulling on this person's
pants just pulling on the front of their
pants by their pockets like on my knees
like basically motioning this toothbrush
down my throat and at first I think the
dude or the I think it's a man now
pretty sure more I remember my memories
getting stronger
cuz I have one of those memories that
gets stronger you know some people
memory that gets weaker my memory gets
stronger so I'm pulling on this man's
front pockets and everything and at
first I think he thinks I'm in caught up
in some you know on some cocaine and I'm
probably doing some [ __ ] off a back page
and I'm running some illegalities you
know I'm probably in my room raising
Turtles you know what I'm saying bro I'm
probably in my room you know making
homemade pesticides and eatin [ __ ]
barbiturates soup up in my hotel room
you know I'm probably making bathtub gin
and [ __ ] you know making towels out
of you know a dead woman's hair some he
probably thinks I'm caught up in
something because if you run out into
the hallway and you're motioning the
toothbrush down your throat you know
that has it kind of like an oral sex
kind of vibe to it and you're crying and
everything but eventually this guy got
what was going on dude and this man is
holding a toothbrush inside of my mouth
to keep my throat open and after about
maybe 45 seconds of that it passed it
passed bro and then this dude is like I
got a run and literally took off like I
don't know if he was like ass like a
Clark Kent kind of do that does this
[ __ ] you know it was just wandering
around looking for people to help but he
helped me and took off could not even
get his information could not even get
his information man [ __ ] I could barely
get his gender or sexuality so but so
that's what happened right when I got to
New Orleans somebody was choking to
death or possibly to death
you know and they didn't and then they
sat and they finished eating they had
dessert and they had other other things
snacks you know and I kept trying to
catch the husband's face he seemed I
mean what was he gonna do massage her
shoulders as she died which would be so
awkward
you're dying somebody's giving you like
a nice massage ah interesting
but outside of that I went away what
else to do I went to a wedding here in
the ones that was cool you know we did
the second line oh if you ever done the
second line thing I put it up on my
Instagram this weekend on the video and
a second line is where they hire you
hire some adult men and it's usually
about like 85% of the men that do it are
African American or black and they
played that they play the big
instruments and they play the jazz music
as you walk down the street so your
whole wedding party gets in the street
and the lady of the bride has the
umbrella or the man if you like a gay
man and you are the you know the fancier
you know if you're the glass slipper of
the crew then you you to one hold the
umbrella and you get out there and you
roll down the street your whole wedding
party is behind you and they have these
a little white like little kerchiefs and
you just shaking that kerchief around
like you're surrendering honest it looks
like once people surrendering but having
fun at the same time looks like a bunch
of alcoholics kind of surrendering so we
did that at the wedding and the wedding
took place an old swingers den the
wedding was a the wedding took place in
this old swingers place where swingers
used to do you know sex I guess an adult
activities and swingers I know in LA
there's some pretty intense swinger
parties I've heard about them you know
and I've actually been invited to some
and I haven't gone yet
because I'm not going cuz my back's
pretty hairy and I'm not taking a hairy
back to a damn swingers it man I just do
not have that kind of confidence you
know in my butt gets kind of hairy too
and I'm not taking a hairy ass into a
swingers thing so I need to get probably
you know waxed up and maybe do some you
know some some different leg exercises
and some reverse leg curls
stuff performed to go to a swingers
thing but I wouldn't mind checking it
out sometime one time I was in Lake of
the Ozarks Missouri and that is swear
country you know that's a good place to
taste another man's wife or you know to
you know really a spray-out on some you
know local spouse it's not Kjersti
nowhere to be wild and we went there me
and this man this other man we went
there we were just comedians you know we
just show up and we're supposed to stay
at Lake of the Ozarks for one night so
we check in at a hotel because we're
doing a comedy show there so we check in
at the hotel we always stay at Wright
and he's the feature I'm the headliner
we're not together we're just friends
[ __ ] honestly me and the student
didn't even know each other
we just know we're both comedians and we
both drove down from the airport in
Columbia Missouri we get there we get to
the front desk the guy at the front desk
goes are you guys girls only boys only
or boys and girls only and I'm thinking
well what the [ __ ] is the third option
for like you know first I'm like what's
going on you know but then I'm like
what's the third what is the third
option even and then we realize that
it's a swingers convention it's taken
over the hotel for the weekend and it's
a beautiful little resort hotel it's
right on the water
you know it's a nice place to probably
you know be by yourself or you know I
guess be with somebody else's spouse or
whatever but then we start seeing people
just bring it in all these little you
know at hotels and motels I got the
trolleys where you put all your goods on
them you wheel them up to your room you
know and a lot of you know a lot of
people bring their own food and
everything and these people were
bringing everything dude I mean you
would see like like a like a like a
everything was from you know Costco or
one of those univers Kirkland
like Kirkland brand you know that big
burn like bulk Kirkland brand you know
rice krispies Kirkland brand lubricant
Kirkland brand like pool toys you know
they had everything and these people
none of them to me were visually
appealing right
that were they weren't appealing to me
but it was swingers right and then you
saw they had this one lady was bringing
in the black guy and you could tell he
was the [ __ ] hammer you know you
could tell this dude was flying he might
have gotten paid to come here and
perform you know he was that dark dagger
you know that air that air that air meet
you know that there was FedEx and around
the [ __ ] country probably to come in
and just satisfy the regional law you
know that regional [ __ ] you feel me
so this dude's hitting the Airways and
probably just you know just straight-up
drilling drilling drilling in different
areas around the countries popping off
you know he's sprouting out you know
he's rooting down and uh and some local
you know and local wives I'm you could
already see like these guys probably had
posters you know that all the white the
white men were gonna be like go get him
black guy you know like Terrence forever
you know [ __ ] like that cuz this dude
was about to pop off on some local wives
and but you had people bust you know
just people with Wheat Thins and all
kinds of big snacks and I'll tell you
this man I wasn't into it at all until
I'm not even joking til I saw the Wheat
Thins
I love Wheat Thins man I don't know who
did Wheat Thins or Pringles but they
they [ __ ] killed it now those are
kind of snacks that would make me want
to be at a swingers thing you know if
you find me I don't know if I'm you know
I don't care who I land in if they got a
bowl of Wheat Thins or Pringles next to
their orifice or you know a little side
tray next to the body dude dude dude
dude dude you know what I'm saying put a
UH
put some floaties on daddy's dick cuz
I'm going in you feel me because I will
I will I will I will perform if there is
a side item of Wheat Thins
or a Pringles you know that's that's a
feast
that's a feast for me and in my libido
that keeps me up but uh but anyway this
place they're like they're like oh you
if you guys aren't here with the
conference
you can't be here with the swingers
convention and we're like what the [ __ ]
you know like we have to be here you
know there was just a mistake they
booked us at the wrong place but I'm
also like what the [ __ ] still does girls
and boys only like that's not even I
guess that means you're open for
whatever I guess it does mean something
actually but but anyhow everybody gets a
bracelet he said you can't have it you
can't have a bracelet you can't
participate in any activities but if you
want to come down and watch the bingo
night
you can like anyway you know whatever
you know we're just we're just gonna be
here for one night so we go to our
comedy show we get back to we have so a
couple of beers at the place at the bar
the comedy spot we get back to the hotel
and we're like do we got a/c you know we
got to go over the mountain you know to
see what he could see cuz that's what
the bear did you know some time you got
to be out there you got to be a baby
bear you know some time if you smell
honey you can't just sit on your hands
if you smell honey you can't sit on your
hands cuz you're not gonna get anything
you're not gonna get any sweetener in
your mouth if you just sitting on your
paws are you some of them you got to
stand up and open your mouth and follow
your nose at the same time if you want
to land your face and some of that
[ __ ] local sweetener so we got up you
know when we start walking around and
peeking downstairs
and downstairs they are doing the
biggest game of what is it with the red
and the blue and the yellow it's like
the handprint and foot and you spin the
dial jeepers you know what I'm talking
about they're doing the biggest game of
that I've ever seen there's like 40
boards hooked together there's like in
the middle there's 19 people who are no
longer playing the game accurately right
there's an old person spinning there's
one woman who is still playing the game
right
still playing like you know right hand B
or whatever it is a right hand green and
then there's 19 people in the middle
just
I mean I don't even know what to say
they were doing I don't know if they
were some of it was sex it was in the
very middle there was something
vibrating in there that was just going
off and that could have been the hammer
you know that could have been the dark
artist down there you know that could
have been you know diandra or whoever
they had brought the hammer you know
that guy could have been just Dewalt
you know that could have been Dewalt or
stalled
you know or black and decker whoever it
was that fellow was popping off down
there you could just you and that's
where the heat was coming out of and
everybody else was just riding off the
vibes and there was a lot of just puffy
adults a lot of seniors a lot of people
in their 60s and you know and even 70s
you know a lot of a lot of that you know
Tampa cleavage where you see a lot of
women have that tan right in the middle
of their breasts but it looks like
they're probably gonna get cancer
they're you know kind of that San
Andreas Fault you know you can kind of
see that they had a lot of some gold
chains you know a lot of bad gold a lot
of bad local gold and then so then we we
we peak and then we scoot right we open
the elevator we're think I'm gonna go up
the elevator man that thing was just a
vertical [ __ ] trolley that elevator was
stacked smelled like oh man somebody
smelled like somebody had left Chinese
food in their trunk overnight and if you
ever done that or not because it's kind
of still got a little bit of a sweet
smell to it but you know that if you eat
it it'll uh it'll upset your stomach you
know that'll make a knees weak if you
eat any of it and that was the smell
that was inside of that of that elevator
at that
swingers convention that we were not
supposed to be at in the first place but
hey that's one of the gifts of the
industry that's one of the gifts of
comedy you know to end up in
environments like that but here we are
we are we are here and whatever day it
is man I'm gonna get into some calls
because I got to go to sleep in a little
bit
because I got to catch a plane in about
let me see in eight hours I'll be on a
plane back to our Los Angeles out of New
Orleans someone catch that drive but I
had a great weekend spending in
Louisiana I got to see my beautiful
nieces and nephews today got to see my
mother haven't seen my mother in about a
year so that was really nice she has a
husband that gots Alzheimer's so you
know he's always talking about the war
and different Wars and so if I see him I
always kind of reference you know I'll
say you know welcome back from bad or
some [ __ ] like that
you know stuff that makes him feel good
and makes everybody feel good so that's
something that I like to do sometimes
you know just make him feel like a part
of you know like they gave them that you
y'all gave them hell you know or you
know stuff like that so pretty pretty
interesting though I had a good time and
went to my knees his soccer game briefly
and then just play with the kids on a
trampoline so it was a pretty joyous man
I got I got nieces and nephews all you
know from age 1 to 9 so it's just man
you get to see how kids are and uh and
they were all happy today so that really
lifted my spirits up a hundred and fifty
percent you know no future swingers I
don't think that I'm gonna seem like
they might get caught up in all of that
you know but we'll see alright man let
me tell you guys what's going on I got a
new tour shirt you can check out out a
Theo von comm slash store it's a tour
it's got all the dates from this past
year it's pretty sweet so go there grab
that support the podcast you can also
support us on patreon where you can
catch extra footage and extra episodes
and that is PA Treo n.com
slash Theo von and that link will be in
the you tube in the YouTube info part
right there please subscribe if you're
listening if you subscribe and if you're
not subscribe and hit up the
subscription B become a part of and if
you got any advice or guidance
constructive criticisms you can always
let me know become a part of the podcast
we're shooting a new pilot for Comedy
Central so also if you live in
California and you have some issues that
are going on with feeling emasculated in
any way
you feel like something that's going on
in present-day society is testing your
manhood hit us up on the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three we're looking for some people to
be a part of that but no fake [ __ ] no
[ __ ] keep it real man keep it 100
all right let's tap into a couple of
calls here thank you guys for being a
part of things let's take it here Oh see
oh man I'm just watching here here
appearances on the church those are two
of the funniest [ __ ] podcast I've
ever seen in my life I think I've
watched them like ten times already
[ __ ] incredible
but uh oh wait hold on this second man
that guy called in but I got I call this
so long it down a little bit let's take
it right here here we go hello CEO the
interesting hearing your perspective on
white privilege I grew up in a town of
500 North Idaho five hundred North Idaho
that's yeah that is pretty white and
there's a lot of mining up there they're
probably just mining even looking for
anyone that is not white like gifted dig
pretty deep thank you for calling onward
so I kind of get what you're saying it's
kind of a hard topic to get into because
I think white privilege does exist yeah
no doubt I mean it definitely exists I'm
just saying that that in my life I
didn't get to sign up for it I wish
they'd have passed around the signup
sheet because it was it was not a part
of my life onward but you know when I
was on a dirt road yeah [ __ ] my dad
was a logger just white trash is [ __ ]
you know people are sharing roadkill or
whatever they shot that hunting season
and logger that's the tree person none
of some people think logger is somebody
this you know you know taking dumps or
whatever all over but logger is somebody
captures trees and I respect loggers but
also at the same time pretty easy job
you know if you were a logger you're
haunting your
hunting trees dude that's easy you know
first of all how hard is it think about
it do it I could think right now if I
really thought about it I could tell you
where there's probably about 80 trees I
could draw I could even probably draw
him for you and draw you a sketch of him
you know an outline sheet of information
so not that tough of a job and I respect
it homework yeah I'd like seven people
in my class one girl she was a goddamn
Squatch - that girl was six-foot when
she was ten ready to [ __ ] some [ __ ] man
whoa okay you got a local law you got a
real [ __ ] Squatch in your locality huh
let's hear more about this Wow girl Wow
girl she did it - somebody had this you
know keep the neighborhood happy and
keep the boys from stabbing each other's
big carry did it they tear their
sickness squishiness
good stuff anyway I'm super stoned but
thanks for the podcast all right
I appreciate the call man yeah you know
you had a girl named big carry that was
taken you know taking on sex locally for
you know to keep the neighborhood happy
and to keep things at bay you know and I
think I think there always is somebody
like that you know I think there always
is somebody like that and every in every
environment you know in every time
period there's some gal who's taking one
for the team and sometimes taken the
team for one you know who is you know
who's just you know comes into their
sexuality you know at a point maybe
others aren't and really just pops off
and makes it happen for everybody
locally and I remember catching up with
a couple of those gals in different
places we had a gal in our neighborhood
it was a swim team she was big on swim
team and she had shoulders like a dam I
mean just like a two-legged bison
brother I mean she just had shoulders
like a dam like a [ __ ] 5'4 French
Bulldog man I mean she had shoulders
like a I mean just like a dam just like
somebody in a wheelchair who lived up a
hill you know what I'm saying
shoulders like that and she used to set
off a bunch of nut she was always set in
people's nuts off setting off the men's
nuts locally and kind of taken one for
the team in a certain age so I think we
should have a time sometimes when we
respect those types of people you know
because because you know they need you
sometimes you need that you know
sometimes you need to take that edge off
as a group as a neighborhood and maybe
that's what these swingers were doing
you know I'm sitting here judging these
people and I would judge and I judge
them at the time but I mean if to be 50
or 60 and you know and not and be pale
and to say you know what I'm gonna take
these thighs out and down by the you
know down into the Ozarks I'm gonna take
these stars out there and set them you
know and warm them up you know make it
these capillaries going and get the
blood flow going you know that's pretty
brave actually it's a lot braver than
some of the stuff that I'm doing so
maybe I can actually learn when I think
back on some of these things instead of
you know maybe this is where I'm
learning where I'm learning not to
really you know judgey swingers you know
but that sometimes an area a specific
area needs to just you know needs to let
out and that those gals out there like
big carry that you just mentioned sir
and that are and that there's just
there's groups getting together just to
pop off you know just a blow seed and
just you know feel that vibe
praise God man let's hear a little bit
more all right hey what's up the oh man
a longtime listener here
my name is Davey I'm not a Kansas City
Davey thanks for calling man I live next
door when I was growing up to a boy
named crazy Davey and he um he used to
invite that one of the neighbors over
this other boy named pug and then he
would hide on the roof when pug was
walking over across the street and he
would shoot him with pellet guns but
that was uh you know just people you
know kids being kids I guess but that
was crazy Davey and he uh he had he was
very very very lean and like to punch
punch out stuff and punch at people and
I remember him doing sex in the woods
locally anyhow onward I know you guys
may have some preconceptions about
Kansas City but it ain't that bad but I
remember you saying something about
callin about what it means to be a man
and and for me I'm a little confused
because I look around about my friends
and everybody on the internet you know
what the average male is looking for is
they're looking for they're looking for
they're looking for a woman they're
looking for a woman to get involved with
and then marry and you know what do you
I just got I got I got no aspiration to
that bro
Wow I appreciate you sharing man I wanna
hear a little bit more about this I
let's continue I just you know I I don't
want to say it's an asexual type thing
but it's definitely a thing to wear you
know getting laid and getting a
girlfriend it's not my top priority I
mean in fact it's pretty far down on the
list I'd rather you know go home and go
to work and just have a good day and
play some music and you know I just kind
of wanted to weigh in on that and hear
what your thoughts might be and maybe
there's other ones out there you just
really don't put getting laid on their
top priority you know I appreciate this
Cole man I really do this is something
that's been on my mind in my heart even
recently and even oh my groin and loins
and that is a sexuality you know it's a
sexuality I also want to say I don't
know if you were doing an impersonation
but you have that you have that you do a
good impersonation mildly of that
scientist that's in the wheelchair the
famous wheelchair scientist I'm not sure
what his name is um I don't know that
they call it you know he's that black
hole you know he's that David Blaine of
space you know what I'm talking about
that a little fella in the wheelchair
beautiful man
but anyhow
I've felt like this man I felt like this
before
you know when all these people are
chasing this legging out there you know
I felt times where it's like am I doing
this just because it's something that
I'm supposed to do do I really even care
what really is my drive like what really
is my desire you know it much just being
sidetracked
because sometimes I would find that I'm
chasing women not even because and
oftentimes I would find I don't even say
sometimes oftentimes I would find I'm
chasing women just because it's a habit
not even because I'm trying to look for
the perfect lady you know or that you
know that I'm searching for love you
know how to find sometimes it would just
be this habit that I fell into that I
guess maybe it was my environment or my
peers you know as I'd listen to other
people in there I'm gonna Fitz conquest
but just you know of course you want to
feel attractive to women but there are
times where I'm like is this really what
I want like what do I like do I really
have any because sex a lot of times just
bores me man I just think it's so boring
sometimes you know just banging your
bodies into each other does bang bang
bang you know bang you know here comes a
crazy here comes a crazy pump right here
by mine and it's not even that much joy
you know it's just like yeah just you
know if it's not like one of you blows
up at a certain point just confetti
flies out of you you know and you you
win or you defeat them you know or one
you know it's not like I think if there
were some prize or something you know
like if you bang somebody enough like a
trophy like you know popped out of their
ass or something crazy I think that
would be more or if there was an old you
know some guy who never graduated high
school you know smoking cigarettes and
chewing on his last two teeth you know
who gave you a prize like a big stuffed
animal or a fish with emphysema or
something you know I think if they had
something like that
you would find more joy in it but
otherwise I have trouble finding joy in
that sometimes you know and maybe it is
maybe these days were becoming more
asexual I mean we don't need it to
survive that much for sure you know it
used to be you needed a child to help
out you know you need a child to collect
wood or get berries you know you can't
make a pie without berries where's the
[ __ ] berries you know so you have a
son you know you got a little Karl or
Clark or whatever your son's name is and
he's out there getting them [ __ ]
fruits you know so you can to you know
cover him you cover them in the distance
but a rifle or an archery piece you know
you're doing your thing you're being
them the leader but now do you need a
kid you know do our joys come from
humans anymore maybe that's part of it
bro I appreciate this call because I
love this thought I love this question
where do our joys come from is it even
other people you know I mean we
definitely lock ourselves away for sure
you know I mean we find like it's
definitely become separatists you know
it's like and it's not good for you
I mean it's definitely not good for you
as a human now as a robot it's probably
great for us you know but yeah it's like
what Oh like are we so are we so
addicted to I mean things are [ __ ]
addictive that's the thing I think I
would love probably spending more time
with people if I wasn't so addicted to
some of this other stuff you know I get
addicted to the dude I've watched a show
on Netflix two weeks ago next thing you
know it's it's 11 days later and I've
watched you know 12 episodes and I'm
like what the hell just happened it's
like you're in a show coma and you're
just going through episode 2 episode
it's just some of it's so addictive it's
so you know it's so shot in such a great
quality and that some of the content is
so good you can get addicted pretty easy
you know so I could see how sexuality
like oh who needs that you know I just
get you know I got 9 4 K episodes of
Ozark I feel like my brain just came for
a month I'm good I don't need another
human
so I think that's something have to
fight if you really want it but it may
be it's not for everybody and I don't I
also don't think it is for everyone I
think you have a little misconception
there and the thing be that everybody's
out there looking for somebody I think
these days a lot of us are out there and
know we may be looking for somebody I
think somewhere in our mind we're also
wondering do we really want somebody or
do we really need somebody or are we
just under this old tradition that has
us looking because we feel like that's
what we're supposed to do you know where
to really it's a it's a weird generation
right now
that's a weird generation but I
appreciate the call all right let's
clack let's crack into something else
here here we go hey Mackenzie from
mechanicsburg I can't remember if you
call before or not or if I played this
call but let's go happily if I also have
props cuz I've been with my girlfriend
for about two years now
Oh Nelly had sex 10 to 20 times and I
think it might be just the pornography I
try to put now what a week so then I
come back to think like wow so this
gentleman from Virginia
and that's Virginia's for lovers bro but
from Virginia is saying that he's been
married for about two years is it
married or just girlfriend but they've
only had sex about 10 to 20 times you
know and then sometime you going these
fits were you jacking off you spraying
out you know I'm saying you petting the
dragon and that dudes firing off you
know blowing skittles out into the
universe
you know you busting them straight-up
galactic shots boy your dicks having a
straight-up DNA asthma attack boy and
spraying out killing local and visible
fires with that splash you know what's
good and sometimes you know sometime you
go on these fits because masturbation is
danger Russ you know I'm saying if
masturbation were a person he would be
wearing a dark dirty cape with dirt on
the bottom of the Cape and dirt around
the top around that brim that brim dirt
and he would be saying nasty stuff to
you and want you to come over under
under under his roof you know want you
to come up under his cape and just be
nasty so you got a watch out you got a
watch out for masturbation man and you
just set some kind of regards for
yourself you know some type of barriers
you know if you got to tape your arms
down at night or you need to get heavier
sheets but you might need to do
something you know or get a neck brace
get a weighted neck brace and wear that
while you rest but if you popping off
constantly on the internet I'm telling
you it's a dirty addictive behavior and
I'm if you know and people constantly
will do will second-guess me on this
this [ __ ] is killing man bro okay think
about it what if they had a soup and
like all this soup is [ __ ] amazing
but it's also killing you would you eat
that soup every night well that's what
you're doing if you can't if you if you
hopped up on these pornographers you
know if you hopped up on these local
high definition you know butt holes and
everything you know in these splashy
crotches then that's what you're into so
you need to get it together that's all
I'm saying because the pornography is
dangerous it is dangerous it's a dirty
road it is a dirty slope and I'll be
damned if you're gonna be able to you
know wear white shoes and do it at the
same time and you know what I'm talking
about but man I'm sorry that you're
having that trouble because I've been
right there I've been in the depths of
it you know I'm two days clean right now
if that jerk and I'm happy about it you
know it's tough it's tough dude but you
know I mean we just were talking tonight
about the asexuality and about the group
sex you know in the tag team and and the
you know SummerSlam and that pus you
failed me like these people out in Lake
of the Ozarks are doing these swingers
and if you are a swinger I want you to
hit that hot line nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three I'd love
to look you know a little bit more about
what that universe is like but I'll say
this to you buddy and I appreciate you
calling is that I wouldn't evaluate it
on the number of times you guys have sex
you know I don't think that matters that
much I really don't you know because
I've had relationships in my life where
I had some decent sex you know when I
was young you know and I think I've
always thought that sober sex is for
children
you know sober sex is for children it is
best served for two people under the age
of 18 you know consensually together but
you know I don't think it matters that
much if there's love there and you guys
are connection that's what matters
because you're coming up on the the
future your life you know what I'm
saying man that [ __ ] gonna die out
that [ __ ] is gonna die out dude if
you went off the interstate somewhere
and you walked into the woods and you
looked around I bet you'd find a lot of
people's libidos a lot of married
couples there [ __ ] history is just
milling out there in the middle of
nowhere because that's tossed aside at a
certain point I think you keep some
sensuality yeah but that's not what it's
about at a certain point it's about a
connection it's about moving forward you
know it's about having a family and
those sorts of things
you know I mean to me men at my age and
at my time in life I mean I've been
through some young trim you know I'm
being caught up you know I've been
caught up in some of that you know you
know some of that soft wallet out there
but the thing that keeps me and gets me
the most these days is that warm hug
from somebody that I love somebody that
cares about me and that's what makes me
feel the most so I wouldn't be hard on
yourself if that's what's going on in
your relationship I wouldn't be hard on
yourself
you know and if you're doing jerking off
to all would find some ways to curb it
because I think that I think that you
think it's not helping you and their
groups you can join online no FAP you
can check that out you know there's a
lot of books about it there's audio
tapes and stuff you can listen to you
know you can go to sa a sexual addicts
Anonymous there's groups you can get a
sponsor I mean I know it sounds crazy
but you know at 9:30 p.m. when you about
to spray down you know when you're about
to just you know clean your sink again
you can call up a dude you barely even
and tell them to talk you off of that
lotion ledge and those men are out there
all right let's take another call here
what's going on Theo this is Alex Cohen
from meta-gene Columbia ooh
Columbia boy whoo I am glad I was not
born in Columbia you know even though my
father said Nicaraguan you know and I'm
polish Nicaraguan if I grew up in
Colombia and I've said this before I
would have got an Eightball for my 10th
birthday and I never would have seen 11
boy I'd have been a couple grams deep
did I've been eating balloons and hiding
[ __ ] slices of cake in my ass boiling
onward I was wondering what your
thoughts were on relationships while
traveling I pretty much travel for a
living different countries and and it
seems like I'm always just cycling
through females but still wanting that
relationship bond and I was wondering
how you juggle stuff like that thanks
for everything and thanks for the call
man I appreciate this call well I'll say
this it's hard to know how you'll behave
until you're in a settled place you know
and I found for a long time I was
putting a lot of pressure on myself to
settle down but at the same time I'd be
out there you know you know checking out
the local flavor you know if you feel me
but and I would always be angry at
myself a bike man you know you you want
to settle down but you you know you keep
[ __ ] up and doing this or not [ __ ]
up but you keep being out there you know
sharing yourself with trollop so you
know and um and you know dazzling around
with these [ __ ] little you know these
little [ __ ] glitter bandits you know
and people that you know chicks has just
already got a toothbrush in a purse and
they just trying to you know meet a man
somewhere late at night at a Holiday Inn
or a Days Inn and just you're come off
you know and you already you know you're
caught up in some of this you know and
some of you'd find a little bit of love
here and there but a lot of it was just
lust you know a lot of it was just
libido fireworks and snapped crackers
you know a lot of it was just a lot of
that so I weren't really you know you
weren't really getting some but I would
be hard on myself I'd be like man you
keep you know I thought you're trying to
find
somebody and I would always be hard on
myself so I just say this man if you're
gonna be on the road it's gonna be
really tough it's gonna be tough not
only for you but it's gonna be tough for
whoever you meet so in the meantime I
think you know just date if you're able
to do that
you know just date you know if you get
into somebody I don't know if I get it
too serious because it's gonna be hard
and you're gonna you couldn't easily end
up hurting their feelings and hurting
your own and I guess I mean I'm just
saying that for me man I mean in the
past I was not able to do it you know I
get on a relationship forget you know
call it up some ladies start holding the
hands and watching a favorite television
show and next thing you know you know
you don't mind if she got a few whiskers
or whatever and that's where you start
feeling some love but then you're out on
the road and you still find yourself you
know you know trying to talk to the lady
that work at the sav-a-center you know
we're checking groceries at the Whole
Foods you know even though she's skinny
and her body's a little bit lopsided
maybe she got a hip issue some dysplasia
but you still find yourself flirting
over by the oranges and you know it's
just you could put a lot of pressure on
yourself you know so for me I could
never do it man I was always lying and I
was always on the run and I feel bad
about it a lot of times for me I just
couldn't do it you know I would get
myself caught up so if you can do it man
more power to you I think it just takes
a strong man you know and it takes a
brave woman and vice versa you know
because they're home alone a lot and
they're susceptible to meet somebody so
for me if I could go back in time and do
some of those things over I would
probably just stay in more of a dating
environment you know and as I've gotten
older that that kind of stuffs gotten a
little bit easier to deal with because
I'm more of an adult but when I was
younger man that [ __ ] was I mean I was
hell boy that was straight hell but look
I appreciate you guys calling man I hate
to jump off early tonight but I think I
got to I think I got to dude let's hit
maybe one more call here one more call
here here we go the corner calling in
here from Louisiana
what's up Conner I'm in Louisiana
right now man onward I was just going in
with a little problem that I have and
something a pattern that I've noticed
that I partake in or half are taken in
over the years when it comes to women
she is uh I will be really interested in
a girl and let's say you know she began
to start showing interest in me okay
your interest is she shows interest
onward and there's this weird thing that
I do where when she begins to show
interest in me then I begin to lose
interest in her mm could be a little bit
of homosexuality maybe but let's go here
and let's say we go on a date or whatnot
and like I'll end up but she starts
selling like initiative I end up getting
really turned off and I don't know what
it is and this happened with a girl a
few months ago I went out with there we
went and did some you know a few things
I don't want to give too many details
but we went out probably talking about
drugs or actually could be told my laser
tag or something sorry homework on a
little date and I went okay and she hit
me up to hang back out with her later on
and I just kind of self-sabotage I don't
know why and I kind of just stopped so
much interest in her stop dancing her
text messages and then she kind of just
went quiet after that what all right
sorry we had an audio issue there the
the batteries [ __ ] [ __ ] the farm or
whatever Jesus I'm in my brother's
living room hope I'm not keeping them
out I hope one of the kids isn't awake
they're sleep right above this floor if
they're here in this dude on work that
well about a few weeks after that
started thinking to myself [ __ ] I [ __ ]
up that was a really pretty girl that I
went to school with and we have a lot in
common why did I do that well the other
day I saw her out with another guy that
I know and it just really made me feel
like [ __ ] because you know kind of
paying some regrets like why did I
sabotage that [ __ ] situation I have
no idea I was thinking maybe you could
you know shed some light on the
situation as to why I'm seen the a like
a be turned off when a girl starts
showing interest in me and B why do I
have
to self sabotage my relationships even
if it's somebody that I think I might
like alright I appreciate the call man
you know what I can relate to some of
these behaviors I can relate to some of
these behaviors because it seems like
you are just going to the next thing
once a girl shows interest that means
it's a girl that you can get that you
are able to get so then you're out
looking for something next you know so
that means either you are it just you
yeah your self sometimes you're you're
not able to make yourself happy you know
and so it seemed like you maybe you're
not looking for the right things you
know you're probably not even able to
see what some of these women are really
like if you're able to move that quickly
from one to the next you know and this
is just from experience man you know
I've missed out on some good some decent
ladies in my life because the second
that they were interested you know or
wanted to catch a little bit of this
route that I would I just leave them in
the forest you know I moved right along
there's something sometimes that's once
somebody's into us we're no longer into
them you know and I think sometimes if
sometimes you just keep going through
this until you find a situation that's
equal you know but I think it would be
nice to maybe give yourself a chance to
to see what it's like if you stayed in
it you know if you just stayed in some
of that let me listen to the end of your
call more time so I can see if I can
relate anymore we have a lot in common
why don't I do that well the other day I
saw her out with another guy that I know
and it just really made me feel like
[ __ ] yeah it's just like you want
everything you know something you want
it all you know you want to you just
want it all and look man I was there
dude I'd be at a party and we get the
beer and then once we had the beer we
needed to be and uh we like we just get
to a party and if the party was good I'd
be like oh there's got to be a better
party going on what do you mean there's
a better we [ __ ] live in a small area
we were lucky to have any party there
weren't no better party well I think
somebody got sac and nip somebody gets a
cannon or someone
doing like [ __ ] mule rods or they got
free coke hanging out there that wasn't
there was I was always thinking there
was something better and always wanted
more there always had to be oh if this
oh then this you know oh we got a van oh
then we should get a waterslide you know
oh we got a waterslide we should get a
[ __ ] we should get a you know a damn
grenade you know it was always you had
there was something that I needed
something better every time if it's
nothing was ever enough nothing was ever
enough there was never any oh I'm just
happy to have this so maybe some of
that's it man and then of course you're
gonna feel bad because your brain is
telling you you want everything your
brain is telling you oh you got to have
everything you know you should have this
you should have that oh she likes you
you got to be somebody else that likes
you you know it sounds like your brain
is taking control of you so you it might
be nice to find some ways to try and
battle that brain you know find some
gratitude you know I make a gratitude
list man I probably do it five days a
week and it reminds me to be a little
bit more it slows my brain down a little
to build a bit more grateful for what's
actually in front of me or at least
think about it and it can be simple
things you know I'm grateful for
so-and-so and a reason why that's what I
write like you know I'm grateful for
Diana you know because she you know she
stopped by my work the other day and
brought me a snack you know when she
does that it makes me feel like somebody
cares about me like gay [ __ ] like that
man but it also makes me feel good you
know when that kind of stuff happens you
just got to remind yourself so you got
to remind yourself I think of things
that are you know a little bit of
gratitude because that can slow you down
and then you're not constantly thinking
of what else can a have because you're
you'll have a little bit more
appreciation for things you do have now
with that said you also might be
homosexual you know you might be in a
cutting up some of that male but you
know you might be thinking of some of
that um that man you know that man back
you know you might be thinking of just
you know being deep into another man and
just
kissing his spine at the same time you
know I don't know there also could be
some of that so if you want to
investigate maybe you know and I'm not
saying you need to be with another man
but if there's a friend you have who is
open to at least just lying next to each
other you know in swimming trunks are in
you know some loose fitting jeans
something like that and just seeing what
it feels like if even the sides yells
arms the sides yells legs are next to
each other and I would take that enough
slow measure but if the side of your arm
feels okay next to him then touch your
leg against his leg I might say anything
crazy am I saying genitalia but I'm just
saying you know feel that vibe now
because me you might have that
homosexual activity going through your
blood and you might want it that might
be your something you're into because in
the meantime you'll find women forever
you know of course it's not this woman
it's not this woman it's not this woman
it's not any of the women because your
libido might be Clinton for a man you
know hunting for that you know more like
chromosome you know if something you
know somebody whose body mirrors your
own and that's gonna be probably a male
body so that could be it man so that
would be the two things I would try
maybe to see what's going on I would try
to be more gracious you know for what's
going on people you're meeting you know
and I do that by having a gratitude list
or I would try homosexuality and see if
that fits you you know there might be
your glass slipper but we've talked a
lot about it tonight man you know we've
talked a lot about it today or whatever
day it is whenever you're taking this in
about sexuality and what's going on and
I think we're a little bit on new
horizon there you know and I think you
have to really ask yourself what do you
want and not be afraid to try it you
know if you want to try you know if you
you know everybody's you know ever we
all service the you know we all fit
somewhere in the sex world you know some
people like you know tons of sex some
people don't like any you know but just
don't let the world or the environment
or somebody else tell you how you should
be sexually because that's where you
start going astray and I've been there
you know I remember actually
the first times I ever partied on drugs
I was here in Baton Rouge and I caught
me some cocaine and somebody said was
performance enhancing drug said I went
for a run i'm thinking
performance-enhancing I'll go for a run
and I ran eight miles on a couple grams
of cocaine you know I'd pull off this
route this this runway this you know
track I was running on you know or this
I just went all around the city and I
would pull off and do me a couple bumps
out in the you know and the palm fronds
are out in the woods and then jump back
on that track and keep running and I was
wearing a pair of orange um bros you
know and just run and yet I was running
so [ __ ] fast boy cuz I'm thinking
this [ __ ] has performance-enhancing and
I'm about to up my auntie you know I'll
probably get a damn four-minute mile son
you know running on cocaine and um bros
but half that time I was probably
thinking my leg thinking about shrimp
thinking about ladies you know we all
got something that motivates us you know
and we all have some where we fit in in
the sexual universe and that's okay you
know but we just I think it is cool I
think it is good and healthy to ask
ourselves what that really is and be
confident in it you know if you want to
try something new try something new and
if someone thinks you're weird for
trying something [ __ ] them they're not
brave for their birth then they're
they're weak for not trying it you know
because it's really it's a it's a wild
game these days when it comes to sex you
know and I think that everybody you know
to each their own
you know but don't be afraid to be
asexual don't be afraid you know to get
on that elevator that's sex that
vertical sex trolley you know even if
the black cameras in there you know
putting that white cross to sleep you
know don't be afraid to try don't be
afraid to get out there all right man I
got to shut this down this week I'll see
you guys next week and and I'll talk to
you guys soon there will be links at the
bottom of the episode on YouTube thank
you guys so much for your support
have a great week man
[Music]
celebrate